le 27 mars prochain ce sera le retour de
l'échappée de printemps l'autre nom de
la roue tourangelle qui fête ses 20 ans
cette année une épreuve reine qui compte
pour la coupe de france et qui passera
dans les plus beaux coins de la touraine
avec un départ de châteaurenaud le
parcours dévoilé à romain delville avoir
20 ans c'est l'occasion de regarder le
chemin parcouru par la roue tourangelle
une course qui a changé de braquet
diffusé en direct à la télé cette année
épreuves de la coupe de france
professionnel mais qui a toujours su
garder sa fibre des territoires
cette année ce sont plus de quarante
communes qui sont traversés par la roue
en 20 ans la roue a bien grandi
aujourd'hui le but c'est de pérenniser
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est arrivé à
un très bon niveau avec la télé et tout
maintenant c'est de pérenniser le sujet
de nombreuses années et de préparer une
équipe derrière moi
pour pouvoir aller au 40ème anniversaire
le parcours 2022 c'est un départ à
château-renault un grand tour dans le
castel renault des passages en pays de
gâtine choisi le pays de racan puis
direction langer villandry et l'arrivée
traditionnelle boulevard jean royer une
course à laquelle jérémy roy a participé
trois fois jérémy roy qui fait
maintenant partie de l'association
organisatrice s'est ouvert ce parcours
comme d'habitude en indre et loire pour
la roue tourangelle
vera des échappées par des tentatives un
peu plus proche de l'arrivée
des baroudeurs des puncheurs ou à ce
prix ça
pour vraiment il ya du suspense jusqu'au
bout 202 km fu panda 2 la bagarre 2022
c'est aussi le retour de la course des
cadets annulé l'an dernier 200 cadets
sont inscrits les champions de demain
qui d'ici quelques années feront partie
pour certains des 19 équipes
professionnelles au programme cette
année